hello everybody today we are going to
discuss really interesting topic of web
development
so for today is going to be
elasticsearch
we are going to discuss some basics uh
and specific software's work
and how to integrate properly with
node.js and some other things
so let's start and actually the very
first question
uh i believe we need to resolve before
we start
is actually why do we need this
technology at all there are lots of
technologies why do we need exactly this
one
so our main reason here is user support
researching
starting from the simplest
landing page and ending with complicated
crm system
they want to search because nobody wants
to waste their time just searching for
content manually actually that's why we
have
google so what does this mean for us
commonwealth developers it means that
actually storage functionality is
one of the most important things in the
entire application
so if your search is not responsive
enough a user
will tell you for sure i don't want to
use your system i'll just go to some
other one
where search will be responsive and fast
so we need to think carefully about
search we need to optimize it and we
need to be sure
that it's fast enough for comfort usage
actually here you can tell me oh okay i
can just do
select from my favorite sql database and
that's it
of course of course you can do it you
can do something like this using like
operator do
some conditions between all the
parameters that you want to have in your
result data set but
there is one big problem first of all
many just i believe almost every
sql databases uh have small disclaimer
inside very documentation about such
operations
which will tell you attention this can
be
heavy operation uh try to avoid usage of
this one
even nosql databases like mongodb have
such disclaimers
another thing what you should take into
account is join of data so when you want
to do
some join operations it can make your
query even heavier and if you just pass
those two things
uh you'll see immediately that you have
a problem with performance especially
when your data site is
large or you need to query many
parameters like we have here
in test client entry um
actually those two problems are
not new ones and developers of
sql databases try to resolve it by
themselves how we could do it
so some of the databases like pos resql
that we are going to use for today
it provides like full text search native
you can try to use this one but you will
understand immediately
but when it lagged just operators so you
can do substring search for example
and actually that's what's not already
serious enough i mean
nobody wants to search starting from
exactly the start of string
you just want to type something see
results and that's it
and actually it pushes us and not only
us because many other developers tried
to resolve those three problems
well first first and second i believe in
the first place and the third one is
kind of a problem for developers
because if you want to use again native
things inside sql database you'll see
problems immediately
and actually trying to resolve those
problems they created something that is
called search engine
actually elasticsearch is search engine
main purpose of the spin is formatting
storing and retrieving of data
so yeah that's simple but one small
exception
when search engine creates something
that is called search index
that set of formatted data it uses some
smart algorithms
to optimize querying for this data
just speeding up your queries for some
data it changes order it can store it in
different format and etc etc i don't
want to go too deep into
such algorithms you can just google them
if you're interested in
uh but the main thing here uh search
engine
actually shaped perfectly for searching
your data and it can do
much faster storage than you will ever
do with native sql
um sql instrumentry
but actually this solution it seems to
be perfect but
to use it properly in the first place
you need to know your data and on the
second one you need to know your queries
so what i'm trying to say here it is not
required
and i believe even forbidden to store
everything that you have inside search
index so for example even here you can
see the difference i have
this set of data inside but i query only
for
some subset from one entry like for six
properties
instead of instead of eight and in the
reality
of this subset of what you query for it
can be even smaller like two
free properties from the entire entry to
search for and you need to know very
well needs of your new user
you need to plan it before you start to
create search index otherwise
will fail because again no magic of
course you have smart algorithms they
speed things up
but they can speed things up just to
store like
uh entry with 20 properties and be
efficient enough
you need to plan everything accordingly
as for any other
technical solutions you need to know
your data need to know your queries plan
everything accordingly before you start
so uh again before uh
before we start with some live example i
want to underline our stack for today
so it's going to be node.js postersql
elasticsearch search engine and angular
on front and side
so and actually our components
what we're going to use and how they
interact with each other
so everything starts uh with front-end
requests to
our api like a user wants to search for
customers
actually customers who have the same
data schema
as we used for explanation before
and actually let's see what happens so
for real of data
so here i have data grid of all
centuries
actually well designed in minimalistic
manner but
anyways i have around 200 pages
so i have 10 000 entries here 50 for
each page
so as you can see we have pretty large
data set uh to search for
and for example i want to search for
some specific country like one two three
four
actually i should have it somewhere
inside account names because i iterated
exactly this one
so and as you can see data comes
immediately just immediately
uh so request is super fast and
if you open developer console and
check the request you'll find exactly
the same
same schema that we used in our chart
so what happened here i send a request
uh
with our search criteria uh that's how
it's going to work on your client side
so the only thing that you need to
provide
for the server uh relevant
rest api point and some storage query
perception and that's it so let's go
back to our chart what happens on
api side by way so uh on the first place
api requests elasticsearch server with
your query
and elasticsearch server returns you
array of ids
like unique identifiers for all the
entries that it found
and after you can use it just for
querying the data from postgresql so
no search actions no substring
nothing is required from your actual
database
so responsibility for searching fully
goes to elasticsearch server
your database is just responsible for
data storage and
getting them back to you and that's it
uh if you know what i want to underline
here as well uh as you can see report
here
is a bit exotic like 9200 actually
that's a standard word for elasticsearch
so
if you just install it your server will
be up immediately and you can start
to to use it for indexing insertion
so um let's tell about
our workflow actually it's related to
data processing so what happens with
data processing
normally client wants to do few things
of the data as you obviously know so it
can request for
create update or delete of entry
actually
read operation already discussed it so
our crowd is not full here but
nevertheless um and what happens here
as you can see uh we want to
operations with data two times i want to
underline it two times not
one because first of all you want to
store something inside your
database like poster sql uh kind of
straightforward
uh but in other hand you want to store
your
search index to search for the data
and actually one more time i want to
underline it
you have data duplication and actually
that's the only way how
search indexing kind of work you
provided some data it stores it
separately it
optimizes searching for these data
chunks and after you retrieve the data
from the database
that's how it works and actually it can
sound a bit
frustrating and complicated because all
approaches with relational databases
will tell us directly duplication of the
data is bad
well not really nowadays because well
this space is not so expensive as it
used to be
and it's not bad when you store some
duplicates to increase performance of
your application
it's kind of a widely used practice so
uh for us that's the only way here you
store duplicates of this data
here the main question now how to
make this approach be easy enough and
extendable enough
and not lose i like connection between
those two type of data well
at least because if you have data
inconsistency you can have some problems
like you store index and elastic search
but there is no related id
inside progress for this data and in
opposite way it works the same so
it can break logic of application uh
and actually we can just provide some
middleware so what i'm trying to say
here
uh in a common way api just tells your
database server postgres in our case
create update or delete entry with sql
query and that's it
but in our case uh a really good
approach would be usage of orm
so object model for our tables not usage
sql immediately from your end point of
course you can
of course if we go to the code and find
our
end point inside rows so
you can see just here i have only get
request because i don't create anything
in application but you can have just
post request next to it
and in the first place send sql query to
database
for enter creation and after you can
just
send an hour query to search engine and
create index there
of course you can but we're talking
about extendable code
which can be actually extended with
extra properties or extra data easily
without rewriting many things
that's why i would like to recommend you
usage of oram for postgresql is a great
term
it's called sqlize so you can try this
one
and basically what does this mean for us
and the matter of the code
let's look into the model actually model
small tutorial for guys who are not
familiar with orum
model is just an object representation
of a table
so so so easy basically it represents
entry inside of a table and it provides
you many methods to interact
uh with your data like creation of
entries
deletion of entries update uh and some
other functionality
the thing what we want to do here we
want to extend functionality that orm
provides to us
so in the first place we want to store
some config for our model for example
we have model customers and we want to
index only few of our properties in the
data like account name city and country
we don't want to store everything
actually that's a golden rule
of search indexing that i actually told
you before
so you don't want to store everything
you want to store only the things
that you are going to search for so
uh in the first place we want to extend
this
model representation for our data with
some
configuration for elasticsearch i
believe
it's quite understandable uh the second
thing
i would tell even the trick
before we tell our main code part like
to api that operation is done
uh before we do it actually we need to
do one
extra action kinda extension
so uh how it's going to work user
requests an update
from api or create or delete you tell to
orm because it's now an
interface for our sql database
it in the first place uh sends a command
to
sql database with appropriate query to
create something or
update something or delete or whatever
and
somewhere between end of this operation
and before we tell api that everything
is done you can notify user but
everything is okay we need to inject one
more action
what will go inside elasticsearch and
create appropriate index for us and
actually that's the truth for
any operation what we want to do like
whenever we want to create
update or delete entry we will just
do this extra operation
so let's look into the code example how
it can be done
actually some of the databases we
already have such functionality
i mean worms for databases like mongoose
oram
uh it has special plugin uh it's
mongoose elastic
and actually it provides set of
decorators for
models and they do exactly this thing
so what's going to happen here
here uh we just take options
for our indexing i said you before why
do we need them
afterwards we're going to say original
operation so
original methods that sends all the
details and does all the magic of
sql database and after
we're going to override our original
create method with extra action so
what's going to happen here
in the first place we do common action
original create we create
entry after the entry is created we're
going to
take all the required data from this
entry
and simply index it inside elasticsearch
and send
exactly the same status that our or
send to api and that's it
and actually you can override any of
factions in this manner
and that's it so all of your models will
auto index
every data that goes for them so that's
why i call that middleware
because it sits just between actual
request and
database and just mirrors all the data
and you can do the same with uh search
requests so you can extend model of
search functionality as well like send
search
and it will just send search to
your search engine and after it will
filter results from the database for you
and that's it
so um one more time how a process goes
user requests something from api you
request from orm
or is extended uh
with mirroring the data into the
elasticsearch server
first of all you save data into common
data storage after you save it here
and it's true for any operation of a
change in the data
so the last thing for today that i want
to tell for you guys
is um well that's basically about silver
bullets
so there are no silver bullets in
development as you obviously know and
if you see that classic search just
doesn't work uh
as you want it to work or your search
query is just well it can be kind of
primitive
more like you search only for one
parameter and only in one model and
it means it's not reason to integrate
one more technology
if search in your case can be done like
with some other ways
like on client only if you have just a
really small set of search results
well just get rid of elasticsearch
server and do it in client side for
example
it can be true for a landing page where
you have just
a really small piece of content you can
just return it
as an object and filter it there
if you see that it won't highlow the
traffic but
if you have a large set of entries that
you need to search through
all welcome elasticsearch on word and
try it
so thanks for attention uh all the links
for code sample
and some other materials can be found
under this video
if you have any question for me please
ask me
and we can discuss it and i believe
resolve it
so thanks for your attention one more
time guys see you bye